can take one question for original
screenplay
so I'm going to make the announcement
shoot your hands up real fast we have
the Daniels Daniel Quan Daniels Daniel
scheinert from everything everywhere all
at once best original screenplay 307.
how you guys doing tonight
is the food good here you guys have
pizza or something okay I'm hungry I
might come after that later okay
go ahead how does this work hi uh Daniel
I'm uh I'm with Central news agency from
Taiwan and uh congratulations
and as far as I know that your mother is
from Taiwan so uh this is a movie or
about the mother so uh uh in this great
moment please tell us what your mother
is like and what the person what kind of
person he is oh my gosh we got to bring
her up here tonight my mom is somewhere
running around celebrating but my mother
is um
honestly the more I grew up the more I
really she's like me
um she is someone who loves to change uh
her passions every couple of years she's
always chasing after new dreams and
she's always doing a really good job of
it and then getting bored and moving on
to the next thing she's someone who uh
sacrificed a lot for her kids I think
she never actually really wanted to be a
mother to be honest and she's told me
that before because she's very candid
which is a very uh very Asian thing to
do
um but I think that actually makes it
even more beautiful how much knowing how
much she gave up for me and my siblings
and and how many years she you know like
one story that she likes to tell is that
when I was really young she read a story
that I wrote and then the next year she
read my writing and realized my writing
had gotten worse and she panicked and
she says oh no my Storyteller is dying
in this this school and so she actually
pulled me out and became a homeschool
teacher for like two or three years just
just to protect my creativity and at the
time I didn't know why she did it but
now I obviously it paid off so that's
like that's the kind of mother my you
know my mom was and uh this yeah this
film is a tribute to that so and yeah
so yeah
so his my my dad is also Taiwan uh
Taiwanese and uh he passed away before
you could see this movie but the movie's
dedicated to him uh Tada means this is
um and uh yeah the joke about raccoon is
very much inspired by my dad he was a
movie buff in the most Taiwanese dad way
where he would always get movie titles
wrong so uh this movie is very much a
love song to our Taiwanese parents but
also Southern parents because there's a
universal there is a universal truth to
our parents and even though it is about
an immigrant story there is something
very Universal about our parents yeah
up we have a question for the best
directing category from film critique in
our virtual Press Room
Hi how are you uh this is Nancy green
with film critique
and uh one of the things that I read was
that the special effects team kind of
learned on the go with doing this movie
so I wanted to know
um as you guys restore storyboarding and
getting everything together how was it
figuring out how you were going to bring
everything
um to the Forefront with the special
effects team and everything not knowing
if you could do everything that you
envisioned
yeah thank you uh we came up in music
videos and would kind of pitch an idea
that we wanted to figure out and then we
would figure it out while we made it and
uh this movie was the same literally the
same crew that made music videos with us
did the visual effects uh Zach Jeff
Ethan and Ben have all worked on our
music videos and those are the core for
the effects guys first names
um but uh but yeah so we don't
storyboard very often we shot list but
like on the day we're figuring it out
and we know what tools we have we know
what tools we want to learn and there's
something I think so inspiring about
making a movie that's going to teach you
something along the way and so uh Ben
Brewer sat and learned blender which is
a 3D animation software while we were in
the pandemic working on the movie and he
was like guys look at this bagel I made
and we're like I think we're gonna do
the bagel in blender and uh and we all
just learned so much originally we did
spray paint the bagel black so just to
see if we could shoot it that way yeah
we did test shoots with Pharaoh fluid
which is like this weird kind of
magnetic metal fluid and it there's
something so fun about you know uh
writing a script that'll teach you
something yeah
great and final question for Best
Picture 331 please
fun
I'm sorry everybody else there's so many
of you thank you for waiting
hi I'm Mandy with CBS News
um no when you went up in a
ugust the awards there was a common
theme of mental health and having dark
thoughts and I think that's common in
the movie as well I'm curious why you
chose to tackle such heavy subjects in
such a lavishly indulgent way with the
bagels and the hot dogs
I love it that's a great question I mean
I think um
we're in a mental health crisis right
now especially the younger generation
they don't have much to look forward to
and there's a lot of you know when you
talk to students these days there's a
there's a bleakness that kind of
um is all pervasive and I I do think
that one of the best superpowers I have
is to be able to talk about my
experience I had a very similar
experience in high school I had a lot of
dark times and I think the radical
transformative power of joy and
absurdity and and chasing your bliss is
something that I am
I want to bring to the people who were
like me when I was that age and this
movie is sort of uh yeah it's a shotgun
blast of joy and absurdity and
creativity
um when I was I shattered out my friends
from high school we used to call
ourselves the rccc uh don't tell me what
that means because I it's a secret but
um but uh they were one of the first
people
um that I I fell into a group of people
that just every single day we didn't
know what we're going to do but we
discover it through creativity and we
would break a lot of rules and we were
like we were really sweet kids but we'd
get in trouble a lot and um that I
remember that in those moments as a
moment of like again it said the the
power of creativity and the way it can
pull us out of these really dark places
and I really hope that the Next
Generation can watch a movie like ours
and just be like oh there's there is
another way to look at the bleakness and
another way to to kind of face it head
on
um that's a great question thank you
there's one thing that I would like to
add is just that the movie The reason
why we ended up making it was because
um we wanted to be able to end up in a
warm embrace at the end of it even
though it was all about chaos and I
think that we all in this room we do a
job that drives eyes to a thing right we
pull people's attention and sometimes we
do it nefariously to and that leads to
problems with mental health and
sometimes we do it with beauty and we
want to instill a certain light and we
are drawing people towards a light and I
would encourage us all in this room we
all work in entertainment we all work in
information that we at the end of the
road there's someone who reads that and
there's an implication of their mental
health and so we have committed Our
Lives to make movies that are good that
will ultimately lead to something good
and isn't just something that will lead
to attention that will then lead to some
Downstream consequences of spiraling so
thank you for what you do uh and thank
you for your wonderful questions thank
you thank you so much and
congratulations
[Applause]